لا اله الا الله
الاثنين السادس من شباط الماضي في الرابعه
والربع فجرا توقفت حياه وبدات اخرى
دقيقتان غيرت كل شيء
لما الزلزال مودنا وبلدات شمال غربي سوريا
واودى بحياه الالاف وهنا في جنديرس كان
النصيب الاكبر من الدمار والضحايا
في جنديرس وحدها قتل 1100 اكثر من
4500 شخص قتلهم الزلزال شمال غربي سوريا
اما مبانيها فتهدم منها نحو 280 وتضرر
اكثر من 1100 كل قصه حياه كتبت هنا سلبها
الزلزال واستحالت قصه موت وماساه
في المدينه المنكوبه
[موسيقى]
تخطر لجنه المهندسين المختصه بضروره اخلاء
المباني المتضرره
اللون الاحمر والدال على الهدم يطغى على
كثير من المباني
انا ابني بعالم بنائي
ولكن اصمم الزلازل في عندي عمليه لازم
اصمم مقاومه حسب نوعيه التربيه هاي
الضعف الجوده ابني كثيره بدون دراسه من
بنت فوق منها طابق طابق صار حمولات زياده
الحمولات الزياده ادى الى تصدع البناء
بشكل عام كملت من الخط الزلزالي لفارق
الزلزالي سبب يعني
ونقص المعداتي وكوادر الانقاذ سبب اخر
لكارثه جنديرس وزياده عدد الوفيات فيها
المساعدات كانت جدا هامه عندما تصل الى
فريق فوز بيضاء في الساعات 72 ساعه الاولى
الذهبيه ستكون كفيله كانت بسحب العالقين
وهم على قيد الحياه ستكون كفيله بوصول فرق
الانقاذ في الوقت المناسب وسحبهم وهم على
قيد الحياه
دربي لم يعد ابنه وعائلته رفقاء درب حياته
قتله الزلزال كلهم هنا يبكي ابنه الاكبر
رفيق
[موسيقى]
والله اشتقت لك والله
وهنا يبكي زوجته وبقيه عائلته
انت واولادك
وهناك يبكي اخته وعائلتها واخاه وعائلته
يا اخي دير بالك على رفيقي وابراهيم
تعرفني
دير بالك يا خيي دير بالك
رحلت عائله الرجل ومثلها مئات العائلات
ولكل قبر جماعي هنا قصه فاجعه اما الناجون
من الكارثه فقذفت بهم الماساه الى العراء
بعضهم في خيام واخرون على قارعه الطريق
لكن كارثه مدينتهم ولحظات اهوالها لا
تفارق مجالسهم
[موسيقى]
السادس من شباط يوم زاد فوق اوجاع
السوريين وجعاه وما تزال تداعياته تكبر
يوما بعد اخر
عمر حلبي الجزيره جنديرس ريفو حلب